hey guys I'm Brent Rose writer and
writer of sharks summer is here and yeah
you could do all the typical things like
barbecue water-ski or you could ride a
jet-powered dolphin that's shaped like a
supercar today I'm going to attempt to
ride two of the craziest watercraft out
there the sea creature is just like a
roller coaster it's designed to scare
you silly and the Jetta me this thing
will blow your mind you can fly this
thing 50 feet high dive it 30 feet feet
so I'm gonna die there's a good chance
you're gonna die great chance so the
first thing we're trying out is the
Seabreacher the Seabreacher comes in all
sorts of flavors there's dolphins
there's killer whales there's all kinds
of sharks there's even a manatee for
some reason so they're all custom-built
most of the boats we build we designed
to look like marine creatures this is
Rob Innes the madman who built these
things how did you get into this I'm
from New Zealand originally the country
known for sort of backyard engineering
it started as sort of just as a hobby
this is the very first Seabreacher we
built I started this in 1999 we've come
a long way I mean that thing was a
deathtrap this thing is kind of
ridiculous it's sort of a hybrid
submarine boat jet ski you can go under
the surface of the water it can jump you
can barrel roll you can go up to 60
miles an hour it weighs about 1,400
pounds you can do all kinds of really
dangerous looking stuff that I am really
excited to try what's the biggest
challenge you think when people try
something like this for the first time
if they're not like trained pilots they
just have to think of three axes like a
jet ski you just turn left and right
this you have to separate your your
pitch roll at your and you have to think
in a three-dimensional environment what
could possibly go around answer you're
going to close the canopy okay and then
your pedals left and right you push the
right pedal it's going to turn you right
push your left pedal that's gonna turn
your left
point your toes forward the nose is
going to go down if you point your toes
back the nose is going to go up because
there's only one air intake off the
snorkel for the cabin and the engine
when you really give it some gas your
ears are gonna pop a little bit there's
a little bit of a vacuum and you really
really feel that a lot when you dive
down and you're gassing it the first
time you go underwater you kind of feel
a sense of panic because it doesn't look
right you feel like you're driving a car
and cars are not meant to be submerged
in the water okay now we're gonna talk
about roll so your lift control stick
controls the left wing your right
control stick controls the right wing
okay so in theory if you push this one
forward and this one back you are gonna
roll to the lift if you do the opposite
you're gonna roll to the right this is
way more high adrenaline than my last
drivers that experience last drivers
have experienced I had a creepy guy next
to me who would always hook my leg and
now I've got that I speak again behind
me who just taps my shoulder oh yeah
the first big trick is learning how to
dive and then jump to do that you want
to be going about five to seven miles an
hour you're gonna pull back on your toes
a little bit and then slam them forward
and that breaks the surface tension gets
her nose into the water and as soon as
your nose is down you gas the hell out
of it
[Music]
if you're in the middle of a dive and
you get scared you're gonna want to pull
back don't do that because then you're
gonna stall out and you're just going to
come out ass first as soon as you're
underneath the water we're going to go
toes back up and your breech through and
generally slam down pretty hard if you
do it right the newest model is the
super car which we're trying out today
they put a ton of R&D into it to reshape
the nose cone and everything and really
really trick it out to make it look like
a certain supercar whose name we dare
not mention so the supercar is based off
C breachers Model Z which has a
retractable snorkel that means it can
barrel roll and that was definitely my
most ambitious trick in it the barrel
roll you have to get up to about 20-25
miles an hour which feels pretty fast
and then you just jam both hand levers
in opposite directions that'll dig one
fin in and lift the other one and you
just spin riding in the Seabreacher is
absolutely thrilling it feels like
you're going Mach 1 and when dive in and
the water is streaming off the
windshield it looks like you're going to
ludicrous speed in your Winnebago I
would say these are for the water sports
enthusiasts who are kind of over there
jet skis they start at the low low price
of 80 thousand dollars that's a very
expensive toy for most people luckily
you can certainly do rental times and
cruise around a lake or even in the
ocean it's a very expensive business to
get into I mean that's what people don't
people think why are these so expensive
and it's just they don't understand just
the sheer number of now is that goes
into building each and every one of
these this is for people that want
something completely different you
didn't destroy my boat so I appreciate
that yeah cool let's try the generator
let's do it what this is is a water
propelled flying bike you hook it up to
your existing jet ski and it it reroutes
the water coming out of the jet pump up
a fire hose and then you can manipulate
the angle of these jets to fly up in the
sky do spins backflips rolls dives
yeah I'm a slightly nervous writer who
goes getting up and writing is a
somewhat tricky balancing act so to
start off you really need to push those
levers way way forward so you slowly
take off at an incline and then you want
to do some more like lean back the
impulse is always to pull back and then
you'll rear up and back flop before you
get the hang of it you will be crashing
over and over and over and over again so
once you're up and riding you're really
just trying to master going forward and
steering while not going over the back
to turn you can either lean kind of like
you're on a bike or you can start using
the thrusters a little bit if you push
forward on one you'll start turning more
in that direction push forward the other
touch any more in that direction now the
first trick that I tried to learn was
the spiral and basically that's you want
to go straight up and spin 360 degrees
and it was way way harder than it looks
essentially you have to start going
straight up and rear back to the point
where you feel like you're about to go
over backwards and you're almost hugging
the thing to your chest and then you
crank the levers in opposite directions
kind of like doing a barrel roll in the
Seabreacher
basically you do a quick spin and then
you try to recover so from there I
actually did some porpoising which is
where you dive into the water and break
the surface and dive into the water and
break the surface and that was super
super fun and not nearly as difficult as
I thought it was going to be I kind of
expected a way bigger impact in the
water and you can really streamline your
body so it's not so bad my last trick
and the thing I'm probably proudest of
today was a barrel roll it took a few
tries and you actually do it from a
sitting position
you have to go up a lot higher than you
think you do which is scary because when
you fall you know you're falling from
higher but when I was able to turn it
around and catch myself before I hit the
water it felt like a massive massive
wind before crashing again
[Music]
I'm really really glad I had that helmet
on because it shook me up a little bit
but overall things amazing the basic
Jenna Vader kit costs about 9 grand
which is a lot cheaper than Seabreacher
but it isn't exactly cheap especially
when you consider you need your own
personal watercraft too that said there
are more and more places where you can
rent these get lessons and try them out
for yourself so what did we learn here
today well when you dr. Moreau together
boats a submarine and a jet ski or a
bike and a fire hose you end up with
something pretty damn awesome
this isn't your Grandpa's motorboat oh
there's an image these are setting the
stage for the weird wild future of
watersports and I'm here for it but what
do you think is this something you'd
want to do yourself let us know in the
comments below subscribe to Wired if you
haven't already with all that being said
there's really only one thing left to do
[Music]